[Music]
rob
is with us rob's in atlanta georgia hey
rob how are you
hey dave dr d how are you guys doing
great man how can we help
i am on baby step 7 praise god for that
um
me and my wife uh we've i've always been
the nerds he's always been a free spirit
i've found we are on baby step 7 by the
way thank you jack
but i've always found that um
i'm only we've led financial peace
university probably close to a dozen
times
but i just recently found some like
credit card that she had
had that i didn't know about nothing's
on them necessarily
um i've always kind of had to
drag her to the meetings and stuff like
that
i know oftentimes the answer for this is
go to counseling we've been the
counseling
we've been married 26 years been
counseling many times and
her ultimate response to all of it is
you are who you are i am who i am and i
don't see the point of going any
further much so i'm kind of had a am i
just
since we're on baby step seven that she
has a a job as well that
she does that we don't incorporate into
the regular budget she does kind of her
own self-care like hair
nails and stuff like that um
just never been completely on the same
page but have great success
ultimately so just need some guidance
looking for some guidance from you guys
yeah brother this isn't a baby step
question this is a
um y'all are on two different pages man
and
this i can't imagine this isn't showing
up in other places
in your relationship besides just
financially where else does this show up
uh well i mean we're not we are on the
same page you know in so many ways
spiritually
parenting sexually um
things like that so so it's just money
she says you be you and i'll be me
i'll keep my paycheck you pay for the
rest of the house i'll take care of me
i'm going to hide stuff and be deceptive
even though i know you're out
like leading classes on how people can
live whole connected lives
everything else is is just above board
and all good
yeah i mean we have a very healthy
marriage so here's what i'm telling you
outside of you
you don't it's not as healthy as you
think it is
and i i i mean if i'm the first guy to
tell you that i'm i'm ashamed of the the
counselors y'all have worked with
um ashamed of your connect your
community that surrounds you guys
but there's some deeper rooted issues
here because this is something that
means a lot to you
that you've put on the block that you've
gone up and presented yourself in a
certain way
to your community members to your church
to your friends to your family
and she's gone behind your back and been
deceptive
that tells me there's deeper cracks in
this thing or just straight up
boat up her back and said screw you i'm
gonna do whatever i want to do
i mean that's the message you've got
it's messaging i heard
right yeah i i'm a grown up i have the
right to do whatever i want to do
and our you know the fact that that is
contrary to everything you
believe doesn't matter i'm gonna do
whatever i want and um it's not about
whether you have a credit card or not
it's about the disconnection
yes this is about about the marriage i
mean if um you're not
on the same page and uh it's there's a
level of
um disrespect here
that that and uh you know if you were
doing this to her
it'd be the same thing i mean if and so
i i you know i don't know john i mean he
he
he said you know more counseling but i
don't think more counseling is going to
doing good
so i i don't know what do you do i to me
that you sit down and yeah yeah
she's not being fully known and he's not
being fully known they're not
being fully honest with one another and
the temptation here is he's trying to
measure the success of his marriage by
the size of his bank account and
that's not how that works man you can
have a remarkable marriage
without seven figures in the bank and
you can have a train wreck of a marriage
or marriage number six or seven or eight
with seven figures in the bank and at
some point you have to sit down and say
i'm gonna have to put all the cards on
the table i'm heartbroken over this
and i need to know what else is there
because i i've nev this would be the
first time i've ever heard
of everything firing on all cylinders in
a relationship
and somebody's saying but i'm just i'm
gonna lie to you and deceive you and not
do this thing over here
but everywhere else it's okay that's
just not how that works man
so there's something there that people
aren't incongruent in one area and
congruent in other areas
not that not that sharply right yeah um
and so there's something else here
you're right if she says i'm not going
to counseling
what you may want to do is go on your
own yeah and say i need to work on
myself because that's all you can
control in this moment you can't fix her
you can't solve her you can't help her
um she's going to have to want to be
plugged in here too and a good counselor
can coach you on how to interact
right differently than you ever have
before maybe yeah it creates a different
result
and without talking to her there may be
things that
you know that rob you're bringing to the
table that make you not a safe place for
her to come home to that make her have
to hide stuff because you're somebody
that flies off the handle you
are filling the blank fill in the
blanket so i don't want to dump all this
on her but what i'm telling you is
man it would be the first of my of my
experience that you guys are
just humming along except for this one
place where she lies to you
and is just completely dismissive yeah
yeah yeah that's just that's strange
yeah
hey thanks for the call that's hard work
i could be more help but so
the recommendation you were right rob is
more counseling that you get a different
one
and someone that's a little more bold uh
and that calls you out on your stuff
and also trains you up on how to
interact with her
to draw her back into the conversation
again because
couples who look at each other and say
yeah you do you i'll do me
this is not a couple this is a roommate
right yeah it's a business partner
y'all done well as a business community
way to go man you made some money